violet tonight spent a long week notable
quotables the state of our union is
strong I said I haven't seen so many
stone faces in an audience since Easter
Island that's not just Bernie Sanders
[ __ ] it's one of the questions you
guys asked over and over and over again
what keeps Nancy Pelosi up at night noon
is this really a stooge for the White
House to do all of this American Civil
Liberties were were abused then that
needs to come to light so that that
doesn't happen again we have crossed the
Rubicon I think mr. McCabe has been
deeply and unfairly maligned thanks
Obama instead of a hand of friendship as
some have said they presented a clenched
fist do it and do it and do it and do it
right they talk a good game with Daka
but they don't produce I'm a person
flesh and bone heart and soul hopes and
dreams Americans are dreamers too
it's seen you don't ever want to see you
suddenly there's a loud bang and things
stop - your reaction to that knowing
that these are he's teaching a bunch of
17 year-olds is well I think the guy
ought to go to hell locker room full of
guys that are ready for the challenge we
all owe and AH in the same way you know
some people take it - yeah one week
there you go it's been quite a week
we've got you covered and come Monday
thanks for inviting us into your home
tonight